[Musique]
dans le cadre des journées européennes
du patrimoine j'ai donc organisé une
visite des oeuvres du campus du campus
vallée à orsay concernant aussi bien des
sculptures que des toiles qui
appartiennent ou 1 % artistique acquis
depuis maintenant les années 60 et 70
par l'université paris sud
aujourd'hui l'université paris saclay
bien évidemment et donc j'étais
accompagné pour ce faire par un
professeur honoraire de géologie qui
expliquait la nature des matériaux
utilisés pour la conception des
sculptures et puis par un street artiste
parce que cette visite aussi concerner
le street art que nous développons de
manière assidue sur le campus vallée à
savoir nous avons maintenant huit
oeuvres qui sont relatives au street art
est donc cette personne a pu nous
expliquer aussi la technique empruntée
pour réaliser ses oeuvres monumentales
dans le cadre du 1 % artistique de
nouveaux bâtiments voit le jour
ce qui concerne l'université paris
saclay et donc il est intéressant
d'essayer de développer la création
d'oeuvres du 1 portion artistique dans
ce cadre très précis
il ya également donc un grand patrimoine
architectural à l'université paris
saclay et donc je m'intéresse essayé à
l'avenir qu'un certain nombre de ses
bâtiments puisse acquérir le label
architecture contemporaine remarquable
qui est l'ancien label patrimoine du
xxème siècle ce label valoriserait un
certain nombre de bâtiments et donc un
travail va être effectué dans ce sens
également ce travail de préservation du
patrimoine et de valorisation de ce même
patrimoine implique une collaboration de
l'ensemble des établissements qui
composent université paris saclay et
donc toutes les bonnes volontés seront
les bienvenues dans l'intérêt est
évidemment de la culture dans l'intérêt
des étudiants qui sont les premiers
usagers de cette culture
et puis bien sûr dans l'intérêt de notre
belle université paris saclay qui a
atteint maintenant le 14e rang au
classement de shanghai est donc
nécessaire que sur le plan culturel et
bien les choses se développent dans cet
esprit et dans ce seront nouveau établi
pour pour l'université paris saclay
[Musique]